inside Justin and Ailee Bieber's wedding
talk about a magical night the Bieber
said I do once again on Monday and you
better believe we've got all the details
let's start with this Jay Lee kissing in
the photo booth at the reception Justin
simply wrote quote my pride is a fire
and it would seem the photo booth was a
big hit the pair and all their friends
posted tons of shots from there and can
we talk about this guest list
kendall Jenner your show of your own
Justine Skye Kylie Jenner baby stormy at
Jaden Smith uh sure ed Sheeran Rory
Kramer Joan Smalls Camilla Marone and of
course
Scooter Braun was there Kendall even
posted this pic of her fight Cara
writing quote we don't date he's just my
date and honestly could stormy and kylie
be any cuter there's also this
star-studded group shot from inside and
here's what we know the ceremony took
place at the montage palmetto bluff in
south carolina and guests took boats
over to the ceremony
Ireland and Alya Baldwin we're
bridesmaids event planner Mindy Weiss
helped to plan the whole thing guess if
Donn moet and Chandon champagne bottles
were made of nine thousand six hundred
and eighty two Swarovski crystals and
took 16 hours to make and how's this for
fresh the night before the wedding
guests were treated to a screening of
The Notebook
oh yeah and there was a water gun fight
now we have yet to see Haley's a full
Bridal look but by the looks of it it
was a white halter gown and she wore her
hair in a bun as for Justin seems he
went for a classic black tux with a
white button-down and black bowtie all
right guys what did you make of the J
Lee wedding let us know and for all the
latest keep it locked to all things et
until next time I'm Katie Krause and bye
for now
[Music]
[Applause]
you